OPPORTUNITY THAT WE HAVE RIGHT
NOW TO RECOGNIZE THE SUCCESS.
>> Sean: JUDGE JEANINE, I HATE
TO DO THIS, BUT WHEN THE
PRESIDENT OF THE UNITED STATES
WALKS IN -- THIS IS YOURS, SIR.
>> President Trump: I'M
EXCITED BECAUSE WE HAD AN
INCREDIBLE DAY IN OHIO, AND AN
INCREDIBLE TIME IN INDIANA AND
NOW WE ARE WITH YOU.
>> Sean: IT YOU LEFT NOTHING
ON THE FIELD, 11 STOPS AND 11
CITIES.
>> President Trump: I FEEL
GUILTY ABOUT INTERRUPTING
JUDGE JEANINE.
>> Sean: SHE WILL GIVE YOU AN
EARFUL ABOUT IT SOON PROBABLY.
[LAUGHS]
I STARTED MY SHOW TONIGHT,
AND -- BY THE WAY, THE BIGGEST
JOKE I SAW THIS WEEKEND WAS HIM
SAYING, YOU DIDN'T BUILD THAT, I
STARTED THIS.
AND I WAS LIKE, NO.
>> President Trump: FRANKLY IF
THEIR AGENDA HAD KEPT GOING, IF
THE OTHER SIDE HAD WON, WE HAD
BEEN DOWN 4.2 OR SIX OR SEVEN,
WE WERE GOING DOWN.
IF WE DIDN'T OPEN IT UP AND CUT
REGULATIONS ON THE WHOLE OBAMA
THING WOULD HAVE COLLAPSED AND
BEEN A DISASTER.
>> Sean: 4.5 MILLION JOBS IN
TWO YEARS AND 4.3 MILLION
AMERICANS OFF OF FOOD STAMPS.
A PATH TOWARDS ENERGY AND
DEPENDENCE, AND I KNOW YOU ARE
DISAPPOINTED.
YOU WANT THE REST.
SPEAK TO YOU BUILD IT AND YOU
NEED IT AND IS YET AND WE HAVE
THE INCREDIBLE MILITARY FORCES
OUT THERE, THEY ARE PUTTING UP
BARBED WIRE FENCES AND WE HAVE A
BARBED WIRE WALL.
YOU SEE WHAT THEY ARE DOING
HIGHEST LEVEL.
WE ARE MAKING A VERY STRONG AND
THE WHOLE THING IN TERMS OF
MILITARY, PLUS WE HAVE A LOT OF
DIGGING GOING ON AND TRENCHING.
APRIL AREN'T GOING TO COME INTO
OUR COUNTRY WITHOUT GOING
THROUGH THE LEGAL PROCESS.
>> Sean: IT'S LIKE WE ARE
SAYING, WE WANT YOU TO COME,
JUST COME LEGALLY.
>> President Trump: THE WHOLE
PLAN OF THE DEMOCRATS,
700 BILLION, BUT THEY FIGHT LIKE
YOU HAVE NEVER SEEM TO MAKE SURE
WE DON'T BUILD THE WALL.
WE HAVE 1.6 BILLION, ANOTHER
1.6 BILLION AND A THIRD
1.6 BILLION, BUILDING IT IN NICE
LARGE PIECES BUT I'D LIKE TO
BUILD IT ALL AT ONE TIME.
THEIR WHOLE PLAN IS TO TRY TO
MAKE SURE WE DON'T BUILD THE
WALL.
THAT'S THE WHOLE THING.
THE NUMBER IS PEANUTS COMPARED
TO WHAT WE DID WITH THE
MILITARY.
>> Sean: $7,000 PER ILLEGAL
IMMIGRANT IN THIS COUNTRY THAT
WE PAY.
THAT'S EDUCATION AND
HEALTH CARE.
>> President Trump: WE LOSE
$100 BILLION PER YEAR ON ILLEGAL
IMMIGRATION.
WE LOSE THAT IN ONE YEAR.
IF YOU SPENT THE MONEY TO BUILD
THE WALL, THAT'S JUST A TINY
FRACTION OF ONE YEAR AND WE WILL
BUILD IT.
WE ARE VERY STRONG NOW.
WE HAVE THE WORST LAWS ANYWHERE
IN THE COUNTRY, CATCH AND
RELEASE, THESE ARE THE WORST
LAWS AND A DISASTER.
THE DEMOCRATS WON'T GIVE US ANY
VOTES.
UNLESS WE RATE ELECT
REPUBLICANS, I WILL SAY THAT WE
ARE DOING REALLY WELL ON ILLEGAL
IMMIGRATION, CONSIDERING THAT WE
HAVE THE WORST LAWS WE HAVE EVER
SEEN.
WE ARE MOVING THOUSANDS OF MS-13
OUT OF THE COUNTRY, THEY ARE
BEING PUT INTO JAILS AND SENT
OUT OF THE COUNTRY.
FRANKLY IN A LOT OF WAYS I LIKE
OUT OF THE COUNTRY MORE BECAUSE
PUTTING IT DOWN INTO JAIL, LET
THEM SOLVE IT.
WE'VE MOVED THOUSANDS OF MS-13
GANG MEMBERS OUT OF THE COUNTRY.
>> Sean: WE HAVE CLOSE RACES
IN FLORIDA.
INDIANA, YOU TAKE THE
LIBERTARIAN OUT AND JOE DONNELLY
LOSES BY AT TEN.
MONTANA, YOU HAVE THE REPUBLICAN
ROSENDALE UP BY THREE.
IN THIS STATE, JOSH HAWLEY UP BY
THREE.
IN NEVADA, DEAN HOLLY HOLDING ON
BY THREE OR FOUR.
ARIZONA, I DON'T KNOW HOW A
WOMAN WHO SUPPORTS AMERICANS
FIGHTING WITH THE TALIBAN EVEN
GETTING 5% OF THE VOTE BUT IT'S
APPARENTLY A TIGHT RACE WITH
MARTHA McSALLY.
>> President Trump: I THINK
MARTHA IS GREAT.
SHE WAS ONE OF THE BEST FIGHTER
PILOTS, SHE WAS REALLY GOOD.
I SPOKE TO SOME OF THE PEOPLE
WHO WENT WITH HER AND HER WERE
WAIVED
WERE WITH HER AND SAID SHE'S
TREMENDOUS AS A PILOT.
I DON'T KNOW HOW SHE COULD
POSSIBLY LOSE TO THE OTHER ONE,
SHE'S TERRIBLE.
YOU TALK ABOUT BORDER WALLS, THE
OTHER ONE DOESN'T WANT ANY
BORDER WALLS OR ANYTHING.
I THINK MARTHA WILL DO WELL AND
I THINK NORTH DAKOTA WILL DO
WELL.
FLORIDA IS A VERY CLOSE RACE AND
IT'S INCONCEIVABLE BECAUSE --
>> Sean: IT WASN'T THAT CLOSE
FOR YOU THOUGH, YOU DID OKAY IN
FLORIDA.
>> President Trump: WE DID
GREAT BUT BILL NELSON IS A
TERRIBLE SENATOR.
HE NEVER CALLED ME.
>> Sean: USED AT THE OTHER
NIGHT, YOU'VE NEVER TALKED TO
HIM.
>> President Trump: YOU'VE
NEVER -- HE'S NEVER CALLED ME
SAYING, CAN I HAVE SOMETHING FOR
THE PEOPLE OF FLORIDA.
WHEREAS AT RICK SCOTT, ALL HE
DOES HIS CALL.
HE WANTS THINGS.
LOOK WHAT HE DID WITH THE
HURRICANES, YOU DID A FANTASTIC
JOB.
LAKE OKEECHOBEE, THEY HAD A BIG
PROBLEM AND IS TAKING CARE OF
THAT.
BUT BILL NELSON, THE CURRENT
SENATOR NEVER CALLS.
BUT RON DeSANTIS YOU CAN'T LET
RON DeSANTIS
LET -- YOU CAN'T LET HIM BE THE
GOVERNOR OF FLORIDA, THAT WOULD
BE A DISASTER.
RON DeSANTIS, HARVARD AND
YALE, A GOOD GUY.
HARD WORKER AND I THINK HE WILL
BE A GREAT GOVERNOR BUT IT'S A
VERY CLOSE RACE.
>> Sean: YOU WANT TO MAKE A
CLOSING ARGUMENT.
YOU KNOW IT'S INTERESTING, I
WATCH THE MEDIA AND THEY ARE
TRYING TO DEFINE THIS AS A TRUMP
MIDTERM.
>> President Trump: UNLESS WE
WIN, THEN THEY WILL GO AWAY.
>> Sean: THEN THEY GO BACK TO
RUSSIA.
IT WAS FUNNY.
BILL CLINTON LOST ABOUT 54 SEATS
IN THE HOUSE.
OBAMA LOST 60 SOME SEATS IN THE
HOUSE.
I LOVE HOW NATE SILVER WE SAID
YOU MIGHT
PREDICTING 87% CHANCE, BUT THEN,
THEY
COULD BE ANYWHERE BETWEEN
15 AND 16.
I
COULD -- I DON'T HAVE TO DO
ANY POLES TO FIND THAT OUT.
IT'S THE AMERICAN PEOPLE THAT
DECIDED IT'S GETTING OUT IN
MIDTERMS -- THERE IS SOMETHING
GOING ON.
>> I LEAD OHIO, THOUSANDS AND
THOUSANDS OF PEOPLE CANNOT GET
INTO THIS MASSIVE ARENA.
I JUST LEFT INDIANA.
THOUSANDS AND THOUSANDS OF
PEOPLE OUTSIDE CAN'T GET --
THERE'S SOMETHING GOING ON.
THERE IS AN ELECTRICITY THAT
FEELS LIKE 2016.
>> Sean: MR. PRESIDENT, I ON
THE WAY HERE IT WAS POURING ALL
DAY HERE FOUR HOURS.
I WENT FOR AN HOUR, I'M
SWEATING -- ALMOST LIKE MARCO
RUBIO THAT DAY.
I LIKE MARCO -- AN HOUR BEFORE
THE SHOW, ELECTRIC, IT WASN'T A
"HANNITY" HAT, EVERY HAT WAS
SOAKING WET.
THERE IS A BIGGER CROWD OUTSIDE
THEN THERE IS INSIDE.
WE HAVE ABOUT 30 MORE SECONDS.
>> President Trump: I'M JUST
HONORED BECAUSE NO MATTER WHERE
I GO, IT'S THE SAME WAY.
IT'S NOT LIKE JUST IN OHIO OR
JUSTIN INDIANA OR JUST HERE IN
MISSOURI, I'M SO HONORED BY
IT.
THERE IS SOMETHING GOING ON AND
IT REMINDS ME OF DOUGAL YEARS
AGO WHERE I KNEW SOMETHING WAS
GOING ON AND YOU KNEW IT AND
PEOPLE WHO ARE WITH US KNEW AT
THAT THEY WERE LOOKING AT EACH
OTHER.
I WILL NEVER FORGET TO GO
REPORTERS LOOKING AT EACH OTHER
MAKING A SPEECH WITH 32,000
PEOPLE AND THEY WERE GOING, THAT
WAS A GREAT TIME AND I THINK
THAT'S GOING TO BE A GREAT TIME.
>> Sean: ELECTION DAY, YOU ARE
GOING TO GET BAD NEWS 5:15 THAT
AFTERNOON, LOST FLORIDA, NORTH
CAROLINA, PENNSYLVANIA,
MICHIGAN, WISCONSIN.
AND YOU WON THEM ALL.
POLLS DON'T MEAN ANYTHING.
>> President Trump: WHEN THEY
COUNTED THE ACTUAL VOTES, WE WON
VERY EASILY.
>> Sean: THE HOME OF RUSH
LIMBAUGH, MR. PRESIDENT, GOOD
LUCK.
YOU LEFT IT ALL ON THE FIELD.
THAT'S THE WAY IT SHOULD BE.
>> President Trump: IT SHOULD
BE.
>> Sean: YOU SAW THE "SNL"
MONOLOGUE --
>> President Trump: I WOULD
NEVER DO THAT.
>> Sean: APPRECIATE IT.
WE ARE OUT OF TIME.
NEWS CONTINUES.
LAURA INGRAHAM IS STANDING BY.
LAURA, HOW ARE YOU.
DO YOU WANT TO SAY HI TO THE
PRESIDENT?
>> Laura: HI, MR. PRESIDENT.
ARE YOU GOING TO CLOSE THIS OR
WHAT?
>> President Trump: YOU ARE
DOING SOME JOB.
VERY PROUD OF HER.
>> Sean: YOU GET THE
COMPLIMENTS ALL THE TIME.
GOT THE INTERVIEW LAST WEEK.
THE COMPLEMENTS.
>> Laura: I DO NOT KNOW WHO IS
MORE COMPETITIVE, YOU ARE THE
PRESIDENT.
TWO OF THE MOST COMPETITIVE
PEOPLE.
>> Sean: I DON'T THINK ANYBODY
HAS YOUR ENERGY.
YOU REALLY LOVE THIS.
>> President Trump: I LOVE
WHAT WE ARE DOING FOR THE
COUNTRY.
I LOVE WHAT WE ARE DOING FOR THE
PEOPLE.
WE ARE REBUILDING OUR MILITARY.
THEY WERE TRYING TO GET IT.
WE ARE DOING A GOOD JOB.
WE HAVE THE STRONGEST ECONOMY
WE'VE EVER HAD IN THE HISTORY OF
OUR COUNTRY.
>> Sean: ONE QUESTION YOU WANT
ME TO ASK THE PRESIDENT ON YOUR
BEHALF, LAURA?
>> Laura: MR. PRESIDENT, THE
AMERICAN PEOPLE ARE DESPERATE
FOR CALM AND UNITY.
WHAT MESSAGE I ARE YOU GOING TO
GIVE THEM AS WE LOOK FORWARD TO
THE HORIZON OF THE FUTURE IN
THIS COUNTRY?
SPEAK THE AMERICAN PEOPLE
LOOKING FOR CALM AND UNITY
>> President Trump: I THINK
SUCCESS WILL DO THAT.
I THINK WE HAVE TO GET OVER THIS
ELECTIONS, SEE HOW IT COMES OUT.
IT WILL BE AN INTERESTING TIME.
I REALLY THINK WE HAVE TO DO
THAT FIRST.
I THINK SUCCESS -- WE ARE HAVING
THE MOST SUCCESSFUL TIME
FINANCIALLY, ECONOMICALLY, THAT
WE'VE EVER HAD.
I THINK THAT'S GOING TO BRING A
LOT OF PEOPLE TOGETHER.
>> Sean: MR. PRESIDENT,
THANK YOU.
LAURA, HAVE A GREAT SHOW.
MY FINAL WORD TO EVERYBODY?
GO VOTE.
GO SHOP THE WORLD.
DO IT AGAIN.
IMAGINE THE PANIC WHEN WE LOOK
AT THE MEDIA'S FACE TOMORROW,